let's me show you how Google can help
you secure some of your most sensitive
data most companies today have a policy
around data minimization the goal being
to minimize the amount of data that you
collect in store to only the data that's
actually needed to run your business but
that's easy to do in words but hard to
do in practice data has a way of leaking
out all over the place so let's look at
a concrete example we have a enterprise
application that a support agent might
use to chat with your end-users and in
the chat you can see Neal's a support
agent and he's asked Alice for some
information to verify her account well
Alice has way over shared we just wanted
the last four of her social she gave us
her full social her phone number and a
picture of her social security card now
obviously we want to store this chat
right to see whether how our
conversations are going or how the
agents are working but like I can't
store that in the database I'm gonna
have half my company now knowing Alice's
social security number so how do we do
that
DLP makes it easy when he ends the chat
we will use data loss prevention to
identify and redact sensitive
information so now you'll see that we
but yes
[Applause]
we recognize over 40 different types of
sensitive info types in this case we've
identified Alice's name if he Scrolls
down a little bit you can see we found
her phone number Social Security number
we replaced all those with red dots and
even we went into the picture of the
social security card found the social
security number there and redacted it
now this chat can be used for analysis
now just to prove this is real Neal has
a webcam over there and we're gonna try
one more example yeah I was in the green
room a while ago and I found this credit
card sitting here and it said or is
hustla I'm just kidding Neil has a
sample credit card with a valid number
but it's not where's this card I trust
DLP I don't trust ten thousand of you
with cell phone cameras so he's gonna
put the credit card number on it he's
gonna hit the button we're gonna use DLP
and it will find and redact the credit
card now this isn't just dumb OCR you'll
notice it didn't blot out the the
expiration date or the name because we
told the API that the only information
we wanted to eliminate was credit card
numbers so you can control the your
definition of PII what's matters to you
so there you have it identity or a proxy
we made it super simple to take a
corporate application and make it
available to our end users without the
hassle of complex network configurations
and with data loss prevention we were
able to help it make sure that you
minimize the amount of data that you
collect so that's one less headache you
have in terms of compliance or
regulatory or really just running your
business